by 6 AM grenisha hasn't heard from Robin
no text no calls
[Music]
when Bernice didn't hear from Robin
she went to the Newark police 16th
Precinct to report Robin missing
she gave a description of the man who
was last seen with Robin and she gave
police his license plate
law enforcement in Newark listens to
renisha's story and her concerns but
technically Robin is just missing
so investigators choose not to run the
plate and give Robin time to show up
[Music]
we're texting her because it was close
to her birthday and we weren't getting
any response her and I were close enough
to where if I text her or call her she
would get back to me
still not hearing from her or knowing
where she was at you know it became a
real issue
[Music]
then on September 13th a father's worst
nightmare
foreign
[Music]